[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce premier
numéro de la nouvelle saison de dimanche
en politique c'était avec un plaisir non
dissimulé qu'on se retrouve à nouveau
dans ce studio en direct le dimanche
matin ça n'était pas arrivé depuis mars
dernier
et pour ce retour c'est la situation
économique et sociale qui nous préoccupe
récession chômage
l'épidémie a durement frappé l'économie
française pour relancer la machine le
gouvernement met 100 milliards d'euros
en deux ans sur la table un plan de
relance détaillé la semaine dernière par
le premier ministre l'objectif affiché
est de retrouver en 2022 le niveau
d'activité d'avant la crise et de
commencer à faire baisser le chômage
alors qu'on annonce 800 mille
suppressions d'emplois cette année mais
ce plan de relance est il vraiment à la
hauteur on en débat ce matin avec nos
invités en respectant vous le voyez les
distanciation sociale évidemment avec
nous ce matin en direct benjamin dit
bonjour vous êtes député de saône et
loire membre de la république en marche
et ancien chef d'entreprise c'est
important dans la discussion que nous
allons avoir face à vous un actuel chef
d'entreprise geoffroy secula bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le président de la ces
pme en côte-d'or également avec nous
carole couvert bonjour sûr vous êtes
vice présidente du conseil économique
social et environnemental ancienne
présidente nationale du syndicat cfe cgc
philippe mexés bonjour je vous êtes le
secrétaire régional de la cgt merci à
tous d'être là en direct ce matin vous
qui nous regarde et vous pouvez bien sûr
réagir sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
hashtag dit mme paul bourgogne alors
avant d'en venir à ce plan de relance
est à votre point de vue sur ce plan de
relance j'ai envie de prendre le pouls
de la situation des entreprises
c'est-à-dire des entreprises et des
salariés dans notre région
geoffroy secula on nous annonce une
crise sans précédent
j'ai envie de vous demander tout
simplement comment ça va bah écoutez ça
va mieux qu'au mois d'avril et ça va
beaucoup moins bien qu'au mois d'octobre
de l'année dernière
la situation économique est encore
difficile et pour parler de notre
territoire plus particulièrement je
dirais que l'hôtellerie commerce
restauration a globalement bien
travaillé en juillet et en août
mais on ressent déjà des baisses
d'activité pour le mois de septembre
puisque les touristes ne sont ne sont
plus là je pense également aux
entreprises qui n'ont pas le droit de
travailler les établissements de
nuit notamment l'événementiel pour qu'il
faut venir beaucoup plus aider ces
entreprises qui ne peuvent plus
travailler
et puis les travaux publics - 40 % sur
le département
les bleus bâtiment -15% c'est l'argent
par valence va peut-être jouer qu'on
espère effectivement et il est là
effectivement pour soutenir
l'investissement
c'est d'ailleurs l'orientation qu'on
souhaitait de soutenir l'investissement
pour soutenir l'activité économique tout
excès même question du point de vue des
salariés on entende parler de plan de
départs qui se succèdent les uns
derrière les autres on a beaucoup
d'annoncés ces dernières semaines est ce
que vous êtes inquiet oui parce qu'en
fait depuis la crise sanitaire on a
d'abord assisté à rupture de contrat
coup de faim cdd d'emplois intérimaires
qui ont donc été les premiers qui ont
été frappés par la réduction de
l'activité ensuite heureusement qu'il ya
eu donc l'activité partielle qui est
venu amortir à la fois du coup les
salariés même si nous revendiquer le
maintien du salaire à 100 % et puis ça a
permis aussi aux entreprises de
conserver main d'oeuvre qualifiée et
puis maintenant en effet on est sous le
coup de restructurations et des annonces
de france regarde de l'emploi souvent de
leur entreprise ou c'est pas justifiée
je prends l'exemple de dons cariste de
jacob delafon près de près de dol ou là
une entreprise qui a été racheté par un
groupe c'est le dernier site qui
fabrique de la céramique est donc en
fait le demain on s'apprêterait à ne
plus fabriquer de ce type de produit
nous dit il ya des gens qui s'en servent
de prétexte de cette crise sanitaire
écoutez c'est les stratégies de groupe
qui sont certainement retard mais depuis
des mois mais qu'on se rappelle le
président macron qui disait que après la
crise a sera plus comme avant
on voit que pour l'instant c'est comme
avant et donc les salariés sont inquiets
évidemment sur la situation du pouvoir
d'achat et la grande menace c'est
évidemment la question de la peur de
perdre son emploi
donc il faut à tout prix que les mesures
qui doivent soit doivent être prises
c'est la question de l'emploi de
l'argument de la précarité et d'une
relance qui participent à ces objectifs
on y viendra certainement tout à l'heure
pour l'instant ce plan de relance ne ne
va pas dans cette direction
carole couvert quel est votre regard du
point de vue aussi du conseil économique
social et environnemental vous avez un
regard un peu global vous êtes de la
région où vous avez un regard à national
un peu global là aussi beaucoup
d'inquiétudes inquiétudes sur l'avenir
et donc la pérennité des entreprises
dans différents secteurs
un secteur du tourisme secteur
industriel secteur de l'événementiel
on nous annonce potentiellement 200000
emplois qui pourraient disparaître dans
l'hôtellerie et la restauration
trente mille dans l'hôtellerie on voit
ji canon 750 suppressions de postes du
fait du court aux navires us or cette
entreprise a touché des subventions
publiques
donc nous ce qui nous intéresse question
oui ça pose beaucoup de questions
justement sur l'exemplarité sur
l'éthique sur la déontologie
ce qui nous intéresse au niveau du
conseil économique social
environnemental c'est non seulement la
reprise d'activité donc la reprise
d'activité ses lacets dans les jours qui
viennent les semaines qui viennent et
après la relance pour construire sur du
moyen et du long terme avec peut-être un
regret on y viendra ensuite dans la
deuxième partie c'est que ce plan de
relance il est tourné sur l'offre est
pour nous il manque un pont sur la
demande soutenir la consommation
mais gouvernement peut encore faire des
annonces à ce niveau là ce qui est
intéressant dans la période que nous
vivons aujourd'hui c'est l'opportunité
qui nous est donnée de repenser les
modèles repenser la gouvernance des
entreprises pour aller vers une
gouvernance plus humaine avec peut-être
davantage de place pour les salariés
dans les conseils d'administration
revoir la manière de partager la valeur
ajoutée ou la valeur créée parce qu'on
va parler partager la difficulté dans
les semaines qui viennent il faut donner
des perspectives aux salariés quand ça
marche quand ça réussit faut partager
aussi exactement et puis surtout faut le
mettre en perspective
parce que ce qui compte dans cette note
qui est extrêmement anxiogène c'est la
manière dont on va recréer la confiance
il faut un électrochoc de confiance pour
que les français consomment de nouveau
et hélas le dialogue est fondamentale le
gouvernement doit de nouveau dialoguer
avec les acteurs des différentes
filières et les partenaires sociaux
benjamin dire qu'une partie de la
réponse à toutes ses interrogations ses
inquiétudes finalement des français
c'est 100 milliards d'euros sur deux ans
oui et une partie de la réponse aux jo
quand même repartir de depuis le mois de
mars puisque c'est votre première
émission depuis le mois de mars on est
bien obligé de de le faire au moment du
confinement n'a quand même une réponse
au monde économique qui était quasi
immédiate avec plus de 470 milliards
d'euros quand même qu'ils ont été
qui ont été déversées temps pour les des
prêts garantis de l'état que pour le
chômage partiel ce qui a pu quand même
garantir une continuité pour l'ensemble
de l'ensemble des français
mais en même temps que l'on faisait ça
d'en discuter on prévoyait l'avenir et
c'est on a discuté effectivement déjà
avec les partenaires sociaux
on a discuté avec l'ensemble des élus
nationaux et les élus des territoires
on a finalement discuté avec l'ensemble
des forces vives de notre de notre pays
d'où ce projet de relance qui ne sort
pas comme ça pourquoi 100 milliards
d'euros 100 milliards d'euros parce
qu'on a perdu 4 points de pib durant ces
cinq mois
1.2 pips et 25 milliards d'euros quatre
fois 25 c'est 100 milliards d'euros
voilà pourquoi 100 milliards d'euros au
départ donc on s'appuie sur poids
puisque on veut aller de l'avant
aujourd'hui l'important ça quand même de
j'entendais je vous entends des tous
inquiets tous les français sont inquiets
des salariés des chefs d'entreprise tout
le monde peut être peut être à quai il
ya des l'état doit être là aujourd'hui
pour pouvoir rassurer rassurer tout le
monde rassuré le système financier
également rassurer l'ensemble des
français il doit être là pour
accompagner doit être là pour relancer
il est là pour prévoir donc c'est ce
qu'on va faire au niveau on en parlera
après de la transition énergétique de la
compétitivité notamment des entreprises
et puis de la cohésion sociale avec un
plan de relance 30 milliards en gros
divisé en trois avec en gros 30 contre
30 et 35 milliards d'euros pour chacune
des grandes parties que je viens de
citer
on va y venir évidemment sortir de la
crise réindustrialiser le pays créer des
emplois accéléré vous le disiez la
transition écologique le plan de relance
déploient beaucoup de mesures en faveur
de nombreux secteurs proposent de faire
le point tout de suite
premier axe la transition écologique 30
milliards d'euros rien que pour les
transports
11 milliards pour le fret ferroviaire où
les pistes cyclables développement aussi
de la rénovation thermique des bâtiments
publics et privés et soutien à
l'hydrogène vert avec 2 milliards pour
créer une filière français
deuxième volet la compétitivité des
entreprises 35 milliards pour l baisse
des impôts de production concrètement
c'est moins de taxes les emprunts seront
facilitées et la relocalisation
encourager enfin la cohésion sociale 35
milliards elle passe par un plan pour
l'emploi des jeunes
aide aux patrons qui embauchent des
apprentis formation ou la poursuite de
l'activité partielle mais d'où vient
l'argent
promesse du premier ministre les impôts
des particuliers ne vont pas augmenter
sur les 100 milliards 40 viendront de
l'union européenne le reste 60 milliards
sera empruntée par la france sur les
marchés financiers ou financé notamment
par la caisse des dépôts
résultat l'endettement va passer de 100
à 120 % de la richesse nationale un plan
d'ampleur qui vise à créer 160 mille
emplois l'an prochain et a retrouvé en
2022 la croissance d'avant la crise
voilà pour les objectifs et pour comment
finalement c'est 100 milliards vont être
dispatchés dans les deux ans qui
viennent geoffroy sait qu est-ce que
c'est suffisant pour vous chefs
d'entreprise écoutez on attendait
effectivement ce plan de relance la
confédération des petites et moyennes
entreprises que je représente a
d'ailleurs travaillé pour faire des
propositions dans ce sens là et bon
nombre d'entre elles ont été reprises
nous le voler qu'on attendait le plus
c'est le volet compétitivité des
entreprises
puisqu'on est champion européen des
décharges en ce qui concerne nos
entreprises
et là ils avaient eu gain de cause
baisse des impôts de production
notamment
ça va dans le bon sens baisse de
production 20 milliards d'euros sur deux
ans via la cvae la crt la séance n'a
laissé les soeurs ne maîtrise pas du
tout hein
tout à fait nous en tout cas c'est notre
poussée de maîtrise bien et ça veut dire
aussi que ce sont
on atterrir sur la fiscalité locale qui
concerne toutes les tpe et pme
le risque était de bouger des impôts qui
concerne que des grandes entreprises
sera été le cas de la c3s par exemple et
ses impôts qu'on vient diminuer concerne
toutes les entreprises de france
et ça c'est important parce qu'on n'a
pas oublié les très petites entreprises
et des petites et moyennes entreprises
toujours sur l'aspect compétitivité le
renforcement des fonds propres il va y
en avoir besoin certaines entreprises
ont pas retrouvé leurs activités et donc
il va falloir soutenir les fonds propres
des entreprises ces trois milliards
d'euros qui sont consacrés à ce sujet
d'ailleurs là ces pme demandent
également à aller encore plus loin un
prêt consolidation de manière à
regrouper les échéances bancaires de
manière à regrouper les charges sociales
fiscales qui ont été décalés et de
laisser le temps aux chefs d'entreprises
de les rembourser
il faut pas se leurrer on parle d' aide
pour on va dire soutenir les trésoreries
mais les entreprises vont devoir payer
ses charges et pour les payer la seule
le seul moyen pour aller payer c'est de
retrouver une activité convenable et
c'est le rôle effectivement de ceux de
ce plan de relance je pense aussi à la
digitalisation qui est un axe fort pour
la ceppm d'accompagner ces tpe et pme
pour numériser nos entreprises et ça
c'est un élément de différenciation
car le couvert ça ressemble par mois en
plus à un plan de sauvetage qui est un
plan de relance la non non rien il ya un
peu des deux quand même 100 milliards
sur 70 mesures
ça a le mérite d'exister ça a le mérite
d'être rapide antérieure certains
milliards sont comptabilisés donné ils
ont déjà été consommés tout à fait tout
à fait pour autant l'allemagne a mis 130
milliards sur la table et annoncer son
plan de relance au mois de juillet et à
la fin un plan de relance qui est
équilibre entre l'offre et la demande
donc moi je reviens sur cette demande
dans les semaines qui viennent d'envoyer
un vrai signal aux ménages pour que la
consommation reparte
parce qu'une partie de la relance
passera par la consommation de ces
ménages et donc nous avions proposé au
niveau du conseil économique social
environnemental d'aller sur un pacte
productif sociale et écologique donc
finalement on se retrouve dans certaines
propositions du mans il y manque et
manque du social et surtout et benjamin
dire ses revenus tout à l'heure dessus
il faut vraiment qu'il ya un discours
maintenant qui rassure qui donne des
perspectives pour ce côté anxiogène soit
mis de côté il va falloir nous
apprenions à vivre avec la pandémie
c'est si c'est pas celle là ce sera
d'autres virus mais en tout cas il va
falloir que nous apprenions à construire
peut-être d'autres modèles et c'est
l'opportunité de cette crise philippe
texier
vous avez entendu geoffroy secula plutôt
satisfaits des mesures et notamment de
la baisse des impôts de production on
imagine que vous regrettez que que le
plan du gouvernement soient basées
essentiellement là dessus pour les
entreprises
oui parce que je pense qu'en fait d'un
plan de relance de l'économie on a un
plan de relance de la politique de
macron en fait on sent pas une volonté
de modifier ce que la crise sanitaire a
mis à mis en lumière c'est à dire la
manière dont les entreprises organisé
leur process de production comment les
groupes ont toutes ces années
externalisée délocaliser y compris en
menaçant l'indépendance d'un certain
nombre d'industries je pense aux
médicaments je pense évidemment au tout
ce qui va toucher à ce qui pourrait être
approché des lieux de consommation et en
fait on a en fait huit cent mille
demandeurs d'emploi et et on a un plan
qui on propose 160 160000 donc avec un
montant de 2,5 milliards donc ça fait
six cent mille euros l'emploi je trouve
que c'est bien payé
donc on a on a réellement une une
stratégie qui manque de lisibilité sur
la réduction de la précarité sur les
travailleurs pauvres sur la situation de
la consommation et en creux en fait on
assiste à une nouvelle étape d'une
réforme fiscale qui dit pas son nom
parce que avec la suppression donc de
l'impôt sur la production
évidemment on allège dans une logique
des prêtres des prélèvements sicot
prélèvements obligatoires donc la partie
de la peau venant de la richesse
produite par les salariés d'entreprises
et mais ça a un impact ça a un impact
sur la capacité des conseils régionaux
notamment qui sont l'une principales
collectivités qui bénéficient de cet
impôt qui à leur tour pour pouvoir
porter des projets de développement dans
les territoires
donc là il ya il ya une impasse et je
pense que
ça peut poser la question en creux aussi
la question des aides publiques qui sont
accordés qui viennent s'additionner à
certain nombre de dispositifs je pense
au cic eux qui a été transformé en
exhortations de cotisation de six points
dans la cotisation de la part employeur
donc on est sur un mauvais bilan on est
moche sur des mauvais choix qui ne vont
pas répondre à la crise économique et la
création des terres alors qu'il faudrait
agir beaucoup plus sur la question de
l'emploi et de la capacité à consommer
des ménages alors benjamin garcia
beaucoup de questions mais déjà le volet
social il ya au moins deux
interrogations là dessus est ce qu'il
existe où il est on le cherche
et puis finalement cette peur du
syndrome cice un sou le sous le
quinquennat de françois hollande c'est à
dire on donne on fait des cadeaux aux
entreprises et au final il n'y a pas de
retour on attend toujours le million
d'emplois du medef mois ajouté des
questions 6e sur lequel nous sommes
revenus à l'allègement allègements de
charges directes et les entreprises dont
qui en bénéficient le plus ce sont bien
celles qui emploient le plus aujourd'hui
le bilan je sais pas si le bilan est
mauvais le bilan que nous avions à voir
la crise c'est un taux de chômage qui
est passé de 10 à 8 % en france dans ma
circonscription est dépassée à 6% il ya
pas une entreprise que je ne rencontrait
pas avant le confinement des rues même
toujours qu'ils ne cherchaient pas à
embaucher des personnes qui ne trouvait
pas ça je pense que c'est notre bilan et
je le trouve plutôt positif aujourd'hui
quand on parle de social qui est la
première des problématiques c'est bien
l'emploi j'y reviens 160 mille emplois
c'est l'objectif huit cent mille
suppressions d'emplois en 2020 c'est le
risque c'est une crainte c'est un risque
il ya un objectif et un risque de
l'autre côté aujourd'hui tout notre
politique vous parliez de la
délocalisation on peut pas d'un côté
être contre et dénonce dénoncer la
délocalisation et je la dénonce avec
vous celle qu'on a pu avoir et notamment
dans des industries stratégiques comme
celle des médicaments alors ça la
relocalisation ça fait par louis laurent
mais oui mais c'est pour ça ont dénoncé
des délocalisations qu'on pouvait avoir
hier et en même temps on est contre le
fait de baisser les impôts de production
pourquoi les entreprises sont elles
partie de votre pays c'est bien parce
qu'on avait des charges qui était trop
importante on diminue les impôts de
production par deux afin de pouvoir re
localiser et d'avoir de l'emploi
aujourd'hui quand on dit qu'on parle de
social
le taux de pauvreté en france les 2 4 il
est de 14% 14% du perso mais au niveau
des chômeurs si on prend que les
chômeurs ses 37 %
donc on voit bien qu'en s'attaquant et
en allant sur le travail vous êtes
d'accord avec moi forcément c'est bien
par le travail qu'on va qu'on va en
premier lieu régler ces choses là
alors est-ce qu'on pourrait pas quand
même avoir bénéficié de contrepartie
très claire des entreprises poserait
aussi la question à geoffroy sécu line
bien sûr une différence entre
conditionnalité et contrepartie
pourquoi pas de conditionnalité au
départ c'est parce qu'on veut que
l'argent soit dépensé très vite il faut
que les choses avec très vite justement
pour soutenir notre économie
d'ailleurs les mesures qu'on a notamment
pour les jeunes les 4000 euros de prise
en charge directement qu'on les prend
aujourd'hui jusqu'à fin janvier 2021
parce qu'on veut aller très vite
on verra ce qu'on peut faire demain mais
il faut aller très vite ça c'est pour ça
qu'on ne veut pas dire additionally
t'aimer et conseil des gouvernements dit
la balle est dans le cas dans le camp
des partenaires sociaux du parlement du
parlement notamment bruno le maire l'a
dit et redit nous l'a dit que lorsque
l'on à travailler parce qu'on a bien
travaillé ensemble ce plan de relance et
vous l'avez dit aussi au niveau des
différentes organisations patronales et
des salariés au niveau des contreparties
ce que disait bruno le maire sait que
les contreparties donc avoir par le
parlement ne pourrait très bien être des
contreparties d'ordre écologique des
contreparties d'ordre financier aussi
certains voudraient quelque part une
augmentation directe des salaires mais
on voit bien que c'est pas forcément au
à ce moment là qu'on peut le faire mais
allez sur plus d'intérêt semences pour
pourquoi pas c'est le chant secula
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à des
contreparties parce que finalement
l'état fait des efforts pour soutenir
vos entreprises
est-ce que nécessairement vous vous
sentez redevables d'assurer la pérennité
des emplois d'augmenter les salaires ou
autre pour permettre la relance
moi je pense que la contrepartie c'est
une fausse polémique tout simplement
parce que ce plan de soutien il soutient
l'investissement et va soutenir
l'activité économique
l activité économique c'est pas des
cadeaux qu'on fait aux entreprises les
100 milliards d'euros et sont pas
respectées directement dans nos pme
mais reconnaissez que ça va vous aider
alors qu'à un moment donné ça doit
bénéficier aussi aux salariés aussi aux
ménages pour qu'ils consomment etc mais
ce sera de fait si le chef d'entreprise
ea se développe il investit il embauche
bien évidemment ça va permettre tout ça
et l'aide à l'embauché pour les jeunes
de moins de 26 ans les aides sur
l'apprentissage les contrats de
professionnalisation
ça doit permettre aussi de ne pas
sacrifier toute une génération
parlais tout à l'heure effectivement de
chômage j'en parlais encore en début de
semaine avec mon conseil
d'administration de la cpam côte d'or
aujourd'hui on n'arrive pas à recruter
dans nos entreprises c'est tout c'est
tout ce qui est contradictoire
on est sur des taux de chômage important
ils vont être encore plus important et
on n'arrive pas à recruter actuellement
je pense que dans six mois effectivement
ce sera plus facile malheureusement mais
le chef d'entreprise quand il a de
l'activité il va bien sûr embauché
investir et se développer et c'est tout
le sens de ceux de ce plan de relance
alors une des interrogations c'est que
vont faire les ménages on disait il ya
quelques instants rétablir la confiance
philippe texier 40% des personnes
interrogées par l'institut et lab
envisagent de réduire leurs dépenses
dans les prochains mois ça augure rien
de bon là il aurait fallu faire un geste
selon vous sur les salaires notamment
oui c'est le sait le débat entre la
question de mesures qui sont sur la
demande et sur la question de l'offre ça
a été dit déjà dans notre pays
ça fait des années que nous emmenait
source syndicale on réclame une hausse
du smic parce que le smic ça al'avantage
donc d'être la base d'une rémunération
pour un salarié lorsqu'il sort de la
portion initial et lorsqu'il est
bassement qualifier c'est pas pour ça
que les autres salaires augmentent les
haies et du coup ça ça entraîne une
discussion dans les branches autour de
la discussion autour des grilles de
classification et de la reconnaissance
de la qualification ça pose la question
si doré aussi les minima sociaux et ça
pose le débat donc pas seulement parce
que je crois que le débat lorsqu'on
discute d'augmentation des salaires
on voit seulement la question de je vais
pouvoir remplir mon caddie mais le
destin d'un salarié s'est pas seulement
remplir son caddie pour la consommation
c'est aussi envisager de s'éduquer de se
former de pouvoir élever ses enfants les
emmener vers une formation plus donc si
c'est possible de pouvoir améliorer son
habitat
enfin ces conditions de vie dans la vie
sociale mais ça participe aussi de ma
vie économique tout à fait tout à fait
donc c'est bien la question est donc ya
pour l'instant un verrou de la part de
ce gouvernement et du patronat sur la
question du smic alors que c'est au
gouvernement de prendre la décision
d'augmenter le taux horaire et laissez
passer pour si j'ai bien compris on
n'est pas parti pour
et donc que ce sujet il est sur la table
comme je pense qu'il faut pas comme ça
repoussée d'un revers de main la
question de la conditionnalité des aides
ça fait des années dans ce pays qu'on
débloque des aides publiques sans
vérifier l'efficacité en matière
d'emploi évidemment l'exemple le plus
criant c'est la question du celi c'est
eux il ya le cr mais aussi il faut
ajouter les exonérations de cotisations
donc du coup y compris qui maintenant ne
sont plus que compensés par l'état
depuis la décision du gouvernement
macron on dit qu'il faut évaluer ce plan
de relance il faut qu'ils soient évalués
par qui il faut d'abord des critères et
des conseils de qualité par exemple
s'assurer que dans ces entreprises là il
ya bien des objectifs de réduction de la
précarité que ces jeunes qu'on va
embaucher et qui vont permettre d'avoir
une prime
eh bien il ya un plan pour qu'il puisse
aller vers un cdi il ya besoin aussi de
regarder comment on va améliorer le
dispositif de formation et de sécurité
donc du parcours des salariées et
salariés aujourd'hui se retrouvent en
grande difficulté confrontés à des
restructurations et où confronté à des
modifications technologiques dans leur
entreprise et donc sont amenés à se
former donc là il faut inventer des
nouveaux droits pour pouvoir sécuriser
le parcours des salariés
il faut aussi des droits pour les
représentants dans les entreprises qui
ont été malmenés par l'homme acron qui a
quand même bien moulinet les droits des
salariés je le parlais de la mise en
place du c est ce qui est bien en deçà
de ce qui a existé dans les comités
d'entreprise présentation de salariés
évidemment car le couvert vous parliez
au début de cette émission de confiance
c'est pas le noeud du problème
finalement on voit que les français par
un homme plutôt que de consommer parce
qu'ils ont peur de l'avenir
on voit aussi que 19 % des français
jugent que les annonces du premier
ministre n'auront pas d'effet positif
enfin auront un effet positif sur leurs
finances seulement 19% ça veut dire que
tous les autres ne le crois pas est-ce
que c'est pas le vrai problème si la
confiance est la base de tout que ce
soit vis-à-vis des chefs d'entreprise
vis-à-vis des ménages c'est le nerf de
la guerre et on voit notre pib a reculé
de 13% au deuxième trimestre à on peut
dire c'est mieux que les états unis qui
ont fait 33 % de recul c'est moins bien
que l'allemagne qui a fait 10 % donc il
faut que maintenant on arrive à la fois
à donner des perspectives aux chefs
d'entreprises parce que c'est ce dont
ils ont besoin sans se dédire et qu'une
partie on les assume
écoute jean françaix du là on a une
partie au travers du plan de relance
attention il va falloir regarder les
annonces en matière de fiscalité
on nous promet pas d'augmentation
d'impôts mais il faut que ce soit tenu
dans la durée
donc il faut de la stabilité de la
visibilité pour les chefs d'entreprise
pour les salariés il y a une vraie
problématique de pouvoir d'achat
certains salariés sont au chômage
partiel depuis le mois de mars ont perdu
du salaire or lorsqu ils sont endettés
que ce soit pour leur maison leur
appartement leur voiture et sont
endettés sur leurs salaires à taux plein
mais pas par rapport à un salaire à tous
réduits donc on va avoir des
problématiques de pouvoir d'achat
s'ils ont thésaurisé ils ne vont pas
libérer leur épargne tout de suite c'est
pour ça que moi je parlais et nous avons
proposé avec thibault lanxade et
françois perret ce que nous avions une
mission sur l'intéressement et la
participation pour le gouvernement
l'ancien l'ancien gouvernement
nous avons proposé de débloquer
l'epargne salariale de façon anticipée
pour des achats fléché achats de
prestations pour rénover sa maison son
appartement achats de véhicules hybrides
ou électriques gros électroménager
pourquoi l'idée c'est au travers de
cette possibilité de redonner confiance
aux ménages et que progressivement ils
libèrent eux mêmes les peintres qui
l'ont mis de côté on a fait une deuxième
proposition qui peut être intéressante
dans les semaines qui viennent
c'est la mode et monétisation des jours
qui sont bloqués sur les comptes épargne
temps on a cherché à chaque fois ce qui
n'allait pas coûter aux chefs
d'entreprises ce qui n'avait pas coûté
au gouvernement et qui pourtant elle est
ramenée de la consommation et dernière
chose est ce que nous pouvons faire tous
ces acheter des produits fabriqués en
france
assemblé en france ça coûte pas beaucoup
plus cher et nous pouvons tous cet
acteur de la relance à la main dès que
c'est ce qu'il va y avoir désormais des
mesures pour rétablir cette confiance
des ménages notamment pour améliorer
faciliter la consommation et la vie des
salariés
alors chacun aimerait dire que quand on
va sur le chômage partiel c'est quand
même bien une aide aux ménages qui est
là elle c'est bien une politique de
quand même de la demande
il faut pas oublier tout ce qui a été
fait avant aussi bien sûr dernier nom
mais sur le dernier projet de loi de
finances quand même c'est plus de 10
milliards d'euros de baisses d'impôts
pour les plus la prime d'activité de 2,2
sommes fléchi en direction des classes
moyennes ou dit vous avez suffisamment
village et ça ça a été fait et je suis
ailleurs c'est moi qui ai porté pour le
coup la baisse de l'impôt sur le revenu
pour les classes moyennes
lors du
lors des grands débats et c'est moi qui
lis qu'il a porté ensuite dans
l'hémicycle jeudi ressasse a déjà existé
ensuite il ya tout ce qu'on a fait aller
sur d'autres mesures plus loin sur
l'intéressement
moi je le dis tout à l'heure je suis
tout a dit j'y suis tout à fait
favorable
pour moi il faut partager qu'on peut
partager plus la richesse mais quand
elle est produite pas avant qu'elle soit
produite
c'est pour ça que je suis pas pour une
augmentation des salaires directs mais
plutôt pour de l'intéressement si les
choses en seconde vous êtes d'accord
pour un contrôle de ce plan de relance
qui soit évaluée avec ma réguler c'est
bien le rôle de l'assemblée nationale
que de contrôler et d'évaluer ce n'est
pas que de légiférer
merci merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat ce matin merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis dans un
instant un point sur l'actualité
régionale suivi de la partie nationale
de dimension politique francis letellier
reçoit aurélien pradié secrétaire
général des républicains je vous
souhaite à tous et à toutes
un bon dimanche
[Musique]